what's going on guys this is Rob if you
guys enjoy my content make sure you hit
the subscribe button and make sure you
hit that little bell so you never miss
out on my sexy voice
okay uh so we are we're back into the
like way too powerful for the Marvel for
the Marvel Cinematic Universe too
powerful for Marvel movies and in this
video you guys knew was only ever a
matter of time you guys knew it was only
ever a matter of time before we dropped
it ah Batman now as we know Batman is
way too powerful for the MCU because if
Batman was in the MCU then it would be
canceled but i'm tish low blow I
shouldn't have said that uh won't
breaker Hulk
okay so we'll break your Hulk oh god
here's the here's the craziest thing
will break her Hulk is bananas right
like he's bonkers The Incredible Hulk
has done some insane things over the
years right like The Incredible Hulk has
had some absolutely insane feats that
have taken place over the course of his
life and the reason why is because he's
a character that's just literally
designed to get stronger and stronger
and stronger like during the ones that
during the original version the original
Secret Wars from 1984 there was a point
where the Incredible Hulk held up 150
billion tons of mountain range which was
kind of crazy that that's that's that's
kind of bonkers when you think about it
like literally it was I can't rule what
happened somebody struck first it was
like Doctor Doom or somebody like that
the superheroes are gonna be buried
under the side of a mountain and The
Incredible Hulk was holding it up and
like it even references that it's like
under 150 billion tons of rock is the
Incredible Hulk and he is not happy or
something along those lines she's just
holding it up with his bare hands and
I'm just like - thats bonkers and um god
The Incredible Hulk number 102 he holds
the car together which is like one of
the most insane feats of strength but
the idea behind the whole world breaker
whole concept was that it was basically
like there had never been a version of
the incredible hope that was more
powerful than that right so so like
start from the beginning right like like
why in the clock back all right let's
run the clock back dude history time so
like one o'clock back and we go back to
greg packs initial run on the story his
initial start on the Incredible Hulk
line of comics and what ended up
happening is the Illuminati deemed the
Incredible Hulk to be too dangerous to
stay on earth like too unpredictable and
and so like that came after a fight in
Las Vegas or something like that do the
Illuminati man okay here's the thing all
right here's the thing all right Fox
like like Disney owning the rights like
the Fantastic Four and the x-men how
long you guys think it'll be before we
for it before we see the Illuminati form
dude I'm so hyped about you I love the
Illuminati I'm so excited about the idea
of the Illuminati like okay so love you
guys I don't know
the Illuminati was Reed Richards Charles
Xavier
Iron Man Tony Stark Doctor Strange name
of the Submariner
no it was it was held in Wakanda black
panther was not originally part of it
Black Panther was like do not do this
right like like you had Brian Michael
Bendis who was riding the road to Civil
War he introduced the Illuminati and and
it was like Black Panthers like do not
do this because if you do it will end
disastrously and it did it ended about
as bad as you thought it would be you
thought it would end but then oh my god
no then you get to Jonathan Hickman's
Avengers and New Avengers and you get to
like the first story arc right like
where the first incursion happens and
Black Panther basically captures like
Black Swan and the other other earth is
destroyed and so that's all I both
universes are saved and like Black
Panther is just kind of like like what
what there's this amazing monologue
Black Panther had like the best
monologues under hickman there was like
this amazing monologue the Black Panther
gives and he's like he's like mother Oh
mother save me you know so it's like
it's like save me from from like
righteous men saved me from thinker's
save me from from like midnight Kings
and the devil himself like referring to
name of the Submariner and he's like
mother Oh mother saved me from what I'm
about to do and like reforms the
Illuminati and it was just like holy son
dude the Illuminati's back to do it was
there was the coolest thing I was
because I was always so hyped and they
dude it did it turns dude then man it it
turns in absolute craziness right like
like the affinity gauntlet gets
destroyed you know like the other
Illuminati members were like look we
cannot we cannot go around his throat
like like like we destroy worlds right
there like we just need to destroy the
incur see Earth's and then that's it
that's all we have to do we have to
figure out a way to do it and Captain
America Oh Captain freedom you know
Captain neo boyscout is like hey guys ah
sure this is like the most logical and
reasonable thing to do and sure it's
like the best decision to make to save
our universe but like freedom and I
can't stand by that and so like Tony
Stark just it's one to just like one of
the dopest moments that count is so
dudes so badass Tony Stark he's like
he's like ok that's how you're gonna be
Steve that I'm sorry and he's like dr.
strain he's like Steven do it and and
Kevin Burke is like what are you talking
about and Stephen strange cast a spell
and then wipes the mind of Captain
America and I was like yeah dude you
just watch Captain America's mind I feel
like I've explained this like a zillion
times before I don't even care cause it
gets me excited every time all's I can
do they wiped in mind a Captain America
just laying on the floor just staring up
you know it's just like dude that's
that's pretty messed up man I think
Captain America learns about it later on
he's just like those guys got to die
like we got to take out the Illuminati
Curtis is one of the cool things anyway
so the Illuminati cast they cast the
Incredible Hulk offer
right in like the crappiest way possible
so what they do is they pair it with
Nick Fury like the old white guy Nick
Fury they pair it with Nick Fury and
they're like Nick Fury we basically need
to get two Incredible Hulk out of here
so a few words like oh hey Incredible
Hulk you gotta help us man there's like
a space station that's gone awry or
something like that some space ship we
need you to go out there we just sort it
all out
and so the incredible gets out there and
like once he gets through he realizes
things aren't really broken and he's
like what in the hell's going on and
this recording place from Reed Richards
and he's like I'm sorry Hulk like I'm
sorry Banner but like you're too
unpredictable we can't let you stay on
earth so they look like we're putting
you in a rocket ship and it'll send you
to like a really peaceful planet and so
he's just like he's like what the hell
man like he's so pissed so like they
like the ship just takes off right and
then like it ends up going and traveling
like a gravity well or something like
that so it ends up on like the wrong
side of the galaxy lands on the planets
a car which is being governed by like
the Red King and you have like
gladiatorial games and stuff like that
and so over the course of the planet
hooks story eventually Incredible Hulk
like Rises as a sacar s'en right there's
the son of the car and like becomes a
new leader after overthrowing the Red
King well then that leads into him like
like basically knocking boost with Kyra
and in the two of them having a kid or
at least her getting pregnant she ends
up getting knocked up and and so like
like they're pregnant and then like the
ship that he was in was like basically
sabotage and it explodes right like the
ship that he was sitting by the
Illuminati exploded and had a nuclear
generator clear powered powered reactor
so like it's us off like this nuclear
explosion and it wipes out everything
but like The Incredible Hulk and like
his warbound and so he's just like like
dude dude men-men i'ma tell you
something man man let me tell you so do
you hope was pissed dude he was bad he
was knew he was mad as hell but he was
he sitting there holding like the ashes
of tyre and he's like the Illuminati did
this and they will all be made to suffer
and it's just like it's like oh man like
man y'all hit man y'all piss off the
Incredible Hulk man y'all seen him in
space man he's gonna be mad at you and I
he got dude he's like he's like let's go
so like they all get me the ship and
they go flying back to earth right and
it's just like it's like man do the
incredible hooks kind of like it's it's
bonkers right like the accredit hook
shows up on the moon and where you have
like black going like like what is it um
man what is that guy's name that the
Inhumans are like Black Bolt and I cares
about the aneema there's this amazing
moment is okay and humans being humans
sucked there's this amazing moment and
Hitman's
Avengers of notice during yet inventors
a new Avengers and it's during the story
of infinity and Corvus glaive shows up
to the Inhumans Royal City and he's like
I heard there was a great king here a
great king of a great of a great Kingdom
all I see here is a small little kingdom
which must be ruled by a small little
King and it's insignificant king that
doesn't actually stand for anything I'm
like man you tell Corvus glaive
eh like man you tell him you tell him
man he ain't nothing man he can just
yell really loud and so on and so like
so for the incredible hook shows up and
like in like black nail black boat was
like one of the members of the
Illuminati who set him out and so he's
just like he's like I didn't come here
to talk right cuz my quotes like I
understand your pain you know whatever
he's like I didn't come here to talk you
look I came here to hear you scream and
just like decimates black ball and black
ball goes to like shout in his face it
doesn't matter dude it's like that oh my
god so that scene from infinity dude
okay you guys know it menu I know what
I'm talking about when Black Bolt
screams in the face of Thanos right like
a scream powerful enough to destroy
planets he screams in the face of Bannos
Antanas like he's like a little miffed
he's like carry them with you to the
missile the best name storytelling I'm
sorry if I'm so excited people but it is
an exciting story and there there are
some really really cool things that
happened anyway so black won't like like
gets crushed bye bye bye be Incredible
Hulk right and then like The Incredible
Hulk shows up on earth with like the
body of Black Bolt is just like broken
just actually reads not dead he's just
like battered all the pieces and the
incredible hulks like this is the body
of Black Bolt and he's like this is what
the Illuminati did they're hiding among
you surrender them to me and you will be
fine keep them hidden and you will be
made to suffer and people just like
they're over there like everybody
everybody so he literally goes through
man i'ma tell you it is it was a sight
to behold
do the Incredible Hulk ghost it's just
like a 1 like it's just just like a
wrecking crew right he showed like the
best part of that part of the whole
story like he fights against the dude
ohh oh my god do you Iron Man's a world
breaker no I was a Hulk buster the
Hulkbuster suit that he shows up with
like Iron Man just like all I got the
whole buster shoot everything's gonna be
ok and incredible actually no it ain't
either
and like crushes that dude he crushes
that suit he was like is this the best
you got man cuz this is about you got
you don't have much of a chance so it is
it's my he goes through has
single-handedly just like captures all
the members of the Illuminati well then
he goes to the Xavier Institute right
like this is after house of am when a
Scarlet Witch took away like 98 percent
of the mutant powers mutant populations
powers and so like by you
and and he's like I want to see Xavier
and I don't want to see him now I want
to see him right now and they're like
they're like ah Xavier is not here like
we don't know what to tell you and
they're like Hulk you need to leave
because he had like doom a cyclops with
a stupid little optic beams because
walking another coke do you need to
leave you need to go home and hopes like
I ain't going anywhere and like well if
you don't leave Hulk then by golly we'll
be forced to write a strongly worded
letter we will make you go home Hulk and
hopes like I can play that game
and just like crushes the like crushes
the x-men right like they do they get
rekt and do the whole the Incredible
Hulk walks in and beats the hell out of
them in their own home like dude he
kicks their ass in their own home so
then like so like Scott Summers like shy
club's just like panic button like he
did he hits it and like everybody gets
called in like Wolverine gets called in
and like even even all the crappy x-men
get called it like Nightcrawler gets
called it the incredible hooks like
don't give a damn and just like dude
Heath man man dude he take some man let
me tell you something man it was yeah it
was it was an absolute murder you the
incredible hope takes him apart piece by
piece and then like hey Marko shows up
with like the juggernauts powers and
Incredible Hulk is just like off with
you like literally they look like
juggernaut starts running they kind of
Hope diverts his moment so he just
throws him the other way and he's like
it's it's like Brad Pitt from Troy he's
like is there no one else is there no
one else and that's what Xavier
basically tells him like look our mutant
rates are down like 298 people there's
only 290 em units left in the world that
we know of and like they're all
basically here in the incredible hulks
like okay well that sucks to be you and
I guess you suffered enough so he ends
up leaving right and they're going back
to think so then like while all this is
going on like Robert Reynolds the
century is like watching everything
unfold and Iron Man and everybody's like
dude century man you got to step in and
you got to do something man because like
you're the MacGuffin here that you're
the comic book like you're the
comic-book
Savior man like you're the guy who just
always manages to pull it out of your
ass because the story calls for it and
so they're like you got to get out there
man and you got to fight the Incredible
Hulk and you got and you got to win and
so Robert Reynolds is like nah man I'm
good like I I kind of feel like you guys
probably deserve this so you know like
go away and then like like Tony Stark
just like it's like the sad Incredible
Hulk walking away music you know is like
[Music]
like the sad walking away music and it's
just it's like like Tori store just has
his head in shame and he's like man
we're all we're all really kind of
screwed up because like nobody's gonna
help us like nobody there's nothing we
can do nobody's gonna help us the
incredible whole turns like Madison
Square Garden like Central Park where is
into like a giant gladiatorial arena and
he's like like Illuminati you're gonna
fight each other to the death and if you
don't then I'll just kill you myself but
like you guys are gonna go through this
whole thing
so finally like Robert Reynolds shows
off right he's like Incredible Hulk you
have to stop and hopes like dude
Reynolds get out of here man like he's
like you didn't like you don't want any
of this man like you don't you don't
want none of this alright cuz like I'm
pissed and and I'm anxious like I'm just
waiting to beat the hell out of somebody
man like I'm waiting man up man I'm
waiting to wile out that's neither else
a credible Superman do this madness
fight breaks many wild now son do that
man there man they were losing it man
they were just like beating the hell out
of each other and everything right just
like sending shockwaves to other plans
like oh man they're gonna destroy the
world it's like it's like Goku and
Frieza fight it's like oh man it might
destroy the world Goku were like anybody
happens to be fighting in the time
manner this fight goes not any longer
they're gonna destroy the world just
like they've never done yet and so it's
just like okay you know like whatever
things are popping off things are
getting crazy and so like eventually the
two of them fight to what's basically
like a standstill tweek they fight to
the point of exhaustion and so what like
The Incredible Hulk is still powered up
here's a crazy thing there's a point in
the story where the Incredible Hulk like
lashes out he gets so pissed he stomps
on the ground and almost destroys the
u.s. like almost like fractures and in
sins of sins like the country just like
breaking into pieces everywhere like it
shakes the entire eastern seaboard of
the u.s. one stomp on the ground shakes
the entire eastern seaboard and it's
just like it's like damn Simon Master
craziest thing I ever seen and it's like
it's like alright I mean this this man
is this is crazy but eventually Tony
Stark launches his satellites which
bombards a then they end up blasting
century and in the Incredible Hulk they
both end up referring back to their
human forms the incredible walks thrown
into prison three miles below ground and
so she's like it's like man is this one
the craziest things but man it speaks
for itself son like that man man come on
man
dude it speaks for itself like there's
there's nothing to be said here alright
it's world break or Hulk like nobody
would believe well burger hole could be
in the Marvel Cinematic Universe if they
did they'd have to nerf the heck out him
like they'd have to reduce him to dust
let me tell you something man due during
that fight with infinity Wars like if it
was world Wicker Hulk vs. Thanos no no
dude it would've been a contest like it
would have been like Thanos would have
been like ho-ho I've got the you know
power saw or whatever in the
we're gonna be like don't give a damn
and just like smash him in one punch and
this be like like Hulk smash like
smashed a nose there's just laying there
all crazed like he'd lay there like Loki
did me Avengers movies like what
happened like the annals goes to attack
incredible team credible just like
knocks him out one punch like Corvus
glaive goes running up on him with like
smelling salts puts his nose he's kind
of wakes up he's like yeah like what
happened where am i he would look like
the black dude from the from the crazy
bus the crazy busca yeah I remember that
back in the day the badass guy that old
Vietnam vet who beat the hell out of
that black dude for giving him [ __ ] man
he was just dude he was a stunt do had
no idea where he was she was just like
he's just like looking around there was
he's like he's like all the amber lamps
Saddles call the amber lamps
somebody called amber laughs that's
exactly what it would be like familes
get the hell beat out of it but no it's
it's cool like it's such a cool thing
but no world wicker Hulk could never be
in the Marvel Cinematic Universe and if
it was it would have to be like the
Marvel Universe vs world were home she
that's the movie I want to see that's
the movie that I want to see I want to
see The Incredible Hulk vs the Marvel
Universe like the Marvel Cinematic
Universe and it's like the x-men the
Fantastic Four and the Avengers all have
to team up to stop world war hulk and it
still doesn't work because because it
wouldn't it wouldn't man like like no
there none of them unless you're talking
about like a reality war / you know like
none of them would able to be a to be
able to stop the incredible whole play
they wouldn't be able to talk world
where all because he's the world record
and here's the craziest thing about that
world Bricker Hulk is not even the
strongest version the Incredible Hulk
with that being said guys we're gonna
bring this video to an end if you are
new here to come this explain make sure
you guys at the sub button to become
part of the rock war if you guys enjoyed
this video make sure you drop unlike and
yeah I will catch you all later peace
[Music]